I want to uh first congratulations let's
start with that I'm making your first
film and I hope this is the beginning of
you making a bunch more but um so I am
curious you've just made your first film
then you've just made your first film
but you didn't put Jesse in it and I'm
just curious if this is the beginning of
you guys swapping where Finn will make a
movie and Jesse will be cast and Jesse
you'll make them you see what I'm where
I'm going with us right yeah yeah it's
kind of a switch I did visit fincet in
very rural Ontario yeah still no role
yeah yeah yeah no I just thought it
would be appropriate for the kind of
just for him to not be in films anymore
right exactly yeah yeah for for people
to stop giving the constant it's based
on my direction right here exactly yeah
well for people that don't realize this
was based on a podcast and I am curious
Jesse how you decided to uh to basically
it's not it's not the same as the
podcast this is a different thing and
how did you decide what you wanted the
film to focus on after uh making the
podcast
well I had written this um yeah the
story for Audible and uh one of the
sections of the book was um told from
the perspective of of Finn's character
and uh and and he was talking about his
relationship to his mother but we never
actually got to meet his mother and that
story
um and I thought uh her perspective was
also so interesting so after I finished
the audible uh book um I decided to
write a story from kind of her
perspective and I also had written his
perspective and I thought it would be
such an interesting Clash of cultures of
ideologies of generations uh you know he
plays a a guy who's um very popular
online uh playing his music to thousands
of adoring fans and his mother is a
social justice activist who runs a
shelter and they uh you know have to
live in the same house with each other
and there's like you know Clash of
ideologies cultures generations and
values then I definitely want to know
when I'm watching the movie I wanted to
uh to strangle your character every time
he says I have twenty thousand followers
online it was you know it uh was it was
it fun playing a role like that or was
it tough saying lines that maybe you
don't disagree with maybe you disagree
with
uh I don't know I I think I kind of had
to figure out how to agree with
everything that he was saying um I think
that's part of the reason why I like
playing the character so much uh and uh
because I kind of yeah I felt really
sorry for him I think
um I also think what Jesse was saying
earlier is that he's incredibly popular
online but very unpopular in real life
which I thought was kind of an
interesting thing which is I I think
what informs him to be so desperate and
annoying and in real life is that he no
one is actually really paying attention
to him in real life and so he finds all
this you know uh
I don't know it's why he dresses the way
that he does or the way that he kind of
talks is because he's incredibly
insecure and I found that like kind of
sad and I kind of really like I related
to the kind of like um feeling the
urgency to perform for people
um and so it was it was weirdly
um I mean it was incredibly
hard
um but I it was a character that I
identified with a lot
um For Better or For Worse I guess yeah
and if if Finn is the most such a sweet
thoughtful sensitive person and so you
have you know this character who's
saying these really pompous things but
told from an actor who's like so sweet
and this is what I love about acting and
why I like writing characters is because
you know when you cast something in a in
a great way by having an actor with
Finn's skill set and his natural
inquisitiveness and thoughtfulness and
sweetness it can Offset you know a
character saying something you know
obnoxious it's why I think a lot of
people enjoy Jason Bateman he says crazy
you know he can he can be very mean but
yet you still root for him right right
right that's we were going with the
paper yeah yeah he said I want you to go
with Bateman yeah yeah give me a box set
of one word two syllables fate man
one of the things though that I really
appreciated Jesse about the film is you
had Julian Moore's character uh work at
a shelter and I don't think enough
um films and I don't think enough light
is Sean is shown on shelters and the
amazing work they do for families in
need uh can you talk about why I know
that's an important part of your life
why was it important to add that to the
film you know what I mean yes yes I've
been um working uh volunteering on and
off with a shelter for about 15 years
um my mother-in-law ran it uh a shelter
in Indiana for 35 years and it's an
amazing place and I had the incredible
Fortune to be able to not only volunteer
there but learn about the wonderful
vital work that they do
um and to get to see inside and see how
an operation like that works not just as
a volunteer but as a son-in-law and as a
husband to my wife who's been working at
the shelter since she's a kid
translating for Spanish speakers who are
in the shelter or you know or or
volunteering and in you know in middle
schools to teach about you know issues
surrounding domestic intimate partner
violence and so um you know when I'm
writing I'm trying to write about all
the things that I know and I'm
interested in and that I hope other
people would get to know and be also
interested in obviously the songs play a
massive part of this movie
um can you sort of talk about for both
of you uh making sure the songs
reflected what you both wanted for the
character or you know what I mean just
getting these things on screen and
making sure you're both happy yeah well
Finn is an incredible musician and a
rock star so you know so he has this
incredible skill I mean the the tough
thing is when you have a part that has a
skill normally you're trying to
desperately Teach an actor to like learn
a little bit like you were on the set of
now you see me where the actors were all
these you know inept magicians trying to
learn magic Finn it was the exact
opposite we had to like make him less
great than he is because he's very
naturally talented so how did you do
that
how did she get and how did you do the
Paul spread um
No I um
I know it was great I mean I kind of
Jesse wrote like the lyrics for like
every song in the movie and then Emil
um who did the score and wrote the music
for the film amazing as well but they
were really nice and letting me kind of
like collaborate with them and put the
little spins on stuff but
um yeah no I I I thought I I it was
incredibly fun to do that um but you're
being humble Finn would we would say
Finn could you just improvise for a few
minutes on camera just play anything
well yeah but the stuff but that's like
this that's like stuff at the end like I
feel like the important stuff in the
songs there's some bigger songs but he
is like naturally so incredibly gifted
and funny and talented and understood
the character and understood like the
limitations of the character's talent to
such a degree that he could improvise
good music in character that's like not
as good as his own music but as good as
what the character needs it was
astounding to watch him and a lot of it
made it in the movie in various places
right yeah this is fun on that note uh
congratulations to both of you uh good
luck with the rest of the Press today
thank you so much